[Music]
it's been six months since Abby Lee
Miller began her prison sentence for
bankruptcy fraud and now a source tells
ET Abby will be released on February
20th she was originally sentenced for
one year and one day in federal prison
our source says after she's released the
51 year old will report directly to a
halfway house in Van Nuys California how
long she is required to stay is unknown
are you concerned about keeping the
weight off in prison no just me to
concentrate on and that's different I've
always put everybody else's child first
before my own house expect a much
different look from the former Dance
Moms star once she's out according to
the source
Abby has lost about 100 pounds in prison
you'll remember the dance instructor
underwent gastric bypass surgery just
before her sentencing people are saying
but your sentencing is coming up in a
couple weeks and this not the other
thing and that is true and I'm really
nervous about that more than the surgery
but there's no right time the source
says Abby is feeling great and has
already requested multiple surgeries for
when she's released including a tummy
tuck breast lift and excess skin removal
[Music]
you